Oberyn Martell: "Unbowed, Unbent, Unbroken."
The words of House Martell.A promise to our
enemies and a challenge to our lovers.
Thousands of years ago, the warrior queen
Nymeria crossed into Dorne from Essos, fleeing
the dragonlords of Valyria. After she landed,
she burned her ships, all ten thousand
of them, so no cowards could slink home.
What a woman. Dornish in spirit
before she ever was in flesh.
She was lucky to land in Dorne, where powerful
women are not locked away in septs and the beds of
old men. My ancestor, Mors Martell, saw her and
desired her, and proved that where armies fail,
a tongue may succeed.
Wedding his strength to hers,
his spear to her sun, they subdued
all of his rivals together. After
the tradition of her people, House Martell
then ruled Dorne as Princes, not kings.
Twice the Targaryens tried to conquer
Dorne with soldiers. Twice they failed.
Only when the dragon kings came bearing husbands
and wives did my ancestors relent and agree
to join their Seven Kingdoms. House Martell
could have waged war until the end of days,
but how could we resist a
peace we could take to bed?
Eventually, after centuries of courtship, House
Martell got into bed with the Targaryens. We took
King Daeron II and his sister for our
own before they could take each other,
and six kingdoms became seven.
Even now, I do not blame my ancestors.
One look at those long silver locks. It is
not every day a man gets to ride a dragon.
But they soon learned that you can't
leap off a dragon at will. My sister,
Elia. She married Prince Rhaegar Targaryen
and became the Princess she already was.
In Dorne, she walked among vipers, and
none would bite her. In King's Landing,
she found herself surrounded by lions.
When Robert Baratheon rebelled against
his rightful king, his future
father-in-law, Tywin Lannister,
ordered his beast Gregor Clegane to murder my
sister along with her helpless children.
And men call the Lannisters "heroes."
Viserys Targaryen: After the submission of
House Stark, Aegon marches towards Oldtown,
steeling himself for another battle.
But he found the gates open, with the
High Septon welcoming him. The pious fool
even had the arrogance to grant what Aegon had
already won, and anointed the last Valyrian as
"Aegon of House Targaryen, First of His Name,
King of the Andals and the First Men, Lord of the
Seven Kingdoms and Protector of the Realm."
Varys: But while Aegon titled himself Lord of
the Seven Kingdoms, in reality,
he held only six. The seventh,
Dorne, had never knelt. Visenya had flown
into the Vale and returned with its crown.
Mimicking her sister, Rhaenys had flown over
the enemy force holding the passes into Dorne
and landed in the castle of its ruling
lady, Princess Meria of House Martell.
Meria was eighty years old, fat,
bald, and blind. Behind her back,
many sniggered at her as the "Yellow Toad
of Dorne." The beautiful Rhaenys probably
thought as much when they met. She demanded
Princess Meria kneel to her brother Aegon,
though she allowed that on account of Meria's age
and health, a simple vow of submission would do.
But the princess told the queen that
the Targaryens weren't wanted in Dorne,
and no Martell would ever bow, bend or
break no matter how badly they burned.
Rhaenys could have mounted her dragon right then,
and roasted Meria in the castle as her brother had
done at Harrenhal. But whatever she saw in Meria's
eyes scared her right back to King's Landing,
with a dragon's tail between its legs.
After Aegon's coronation, Rhaenys
returned to Dorne with Aegon and Visenya
and their dragons. But no armies met them in the
field, and no lords defied them in their castles.
As the dragons approached, Dorne simply emptied.
House Martell had learned from Harrenhal
and the Field of Fire. The dragons were unbeatable
in battle, but wars were more than battles.
Unopposed, Aegon claimed Dorne for his own.
But as soon as he returned to King's Landing,
his castellans were hurled off towers, and his
royal garrison vanished in the desert, never to be
seen again. Except, perhaps, when the winds change
and the sands cough up old bones and armor.Rhaenys
returned on Meraxes, intent
on avenging herself against
Meria Martell. But Dorne was no longer empty.
The Dornish kept Meria's promise and fought even
while burning under dragon flame. And they won.
One day a bolt pierced the eye of Meraxes and
knocked the dragon out of the sky. House Martell
remained unbroken, unlike the unfortunate Rhaenys.
In their wrath, Aegon and Visenya set flame to
every castle and city but Sunspear, trying to
turn the people against House Martell. But the
Dornish stayed loyal, and when Aegon returned
to King's Landing, he found assassins waiting
for him in the streets of his own capital.
If not for Visenya, the Conqueror would not
have enjoyed his conquest for very long.
From then on, the king and his family would
be guarded by the seven greatest knights
in the realm: the Kingsguard.
When Meria died in her sleep,
a weak and tired son sued for peace. But
old Meria had exhausted Aegon as well,
and he granted the request. The Targaryens still
wanted Dorne, and eventually, they would have it,
but not at the point of a sword. They would
buy it the same way great lords buy anything:
with a daughter.
Ellaria Sand: Before the Seven Kingdoms,
before the Iron Throne, there was Dorne.
Twelve thousand years ago, the First Men
crossed the land bridge from Essos to here. Of
course, they were men, so they soon broke it.
Then, while their cousins to the North built
kingdoms, the Dornish squabbled over land, water,
and wives for centuries. Until
Nymeria, a warrior princess in Essos.
She led a fleet of ten thousand
ships across the Narrow Sea to Dorne.
Almost all of the petty lords made
it clear that she wasn't welcome.
All but one. Mors of House Martell.
He saw in her a strength to match any man,
including his rivals. After she accepted his
marriage offer, she set fire to her ships.
For fifty leagues, the coast was bright as
day, and in the burning light, Princess Nymeria
named Mors Martell the Prince of
Dorne, in the style of her people.
Dorne would be her home or her grave.
For many years, Nymeria and Mors waged war against
all rivals. The Jordaynes, Blackmonts, Qorgyles,
and even the mighty House Yronwood. They sent no
fewer than six self-styled "kings" to the Wall
in golden chains. After Mors fell in battle,
Nymeria took command of his armies
and united Dorne in two years.
She ruled for twenty-seven more, and though
she married again, those husbands were
little more than councilors and consorts.
Dorne was Nymeria, and Nymeria was Dorne.
She survived a dozen attempts on her life, put
down two rebellions, and threw back two invasions.
And when at last, she died, her eldest child
succeeded her (her daughter, not her son),
and Dorne followed her because Nymeria had proven
that women were equal to men, if not better.
Centuries later, Aegon Targaryen
sought to unite Westeros,
as Nymeria had Dorne. The other six kingdoms
fell quickly before his dragons and ambition.
When his sister-wife, Rhaenys, flew her dragon
south and demanded Dorne's surrender as well,
Princess Meria Martell warned, "I will
not fight you, nor will I kneel to you.
Dorne has no king. Tell your brother that."
Rhaenys threatened that the next time the
Targaryens would come with fire and blood.
Meria replied, "You may burn us,
my lady, but you will not bend us,
break us or make us bow. This is Dorne; you
are not wanted here. Return at your peril!"
Rhaenys did, and she died. Her dragon
died. All her soldiers died. Eventually,
her brother, the Conqueror, conceded that
what Nymeria had done, he could not undo.
Generations later, another
foolish Targaryen invaded Dorne.
He died as well. Eventually, we did join the Seven
Kingdoms, but when we wanted and on our terms.
If dragons could not conquer
us, why should we fear lions?
"Unbowed, unbent, unbroken." The words of House
Martell.The words of Dorne. Men may forget,
but women always remember. When we were divided,
Nymeria united us. When we were
invaded, Meria defended us.